the first day in a new sort of britain
fears of border cues and delay at dover
didn't materialize
it was in fact unusually quiet
[Music]
a relief to many not least one italian
driver with a newborn baby to get home
to she's my princess
the next time next time i come here
i i think maybe there are
then maybe there are problems
with brexit usually this part would be
full of lorries taking a quick pit stop
before heading over to france but it's
much
much quieter than normal that's partly
because it's a bank holiday
but it's also because many businesses
push to move their goods
through the border before the brexit
deadline it may mean calm for a few days
but it's unlikely to last there's huge
change afoot
new customs forms and checks new permits
to enter kent
new rules and restrictions on some
products for those who did brave the
border
problems were starting to play out
it's a little mess three hours waiting
for papers
charles hogg is a customs broker and
expects major issues later this month
we're going to see the delays coming
over the coming weeks and months
not necessarily even in the first few
weeks of january
i see very much that come hopefully by
february it will return to businesses
as usual however what will happen is a
lot of these unprepared importers
will get fines they will get extra truck
waiting time
and have a lot of additional costs and
much will fall at the door of small
business
and that that application step process
is a 15
step process mike's company imports and
exports asian food to europe
he thinks these changes could wipe 10 of
his company
today we are now encumbered with
customs procedures and security and
safety measures and checks
and declarations so do you actually
think you're you'll lose business
because of these new arrangements
undoubtedly because we have customers
who are
ill prepared to the requirements of
international trade
and decorations
daiso rondova other businesses run from
other ports were also digesting the
changes
uk fishing boats will get a greater
share of uk fish
the eu boats will remain many were
hoping for more
it would have been great to have had
something to sort of look forward to
maybe i'm skeptical but we always seem
to get the poor end of the stick beneath
the surface trade in this country has
fundamentally changed an entirely new
era has begun
the reality and the impact may take some
time to untangle
helen and smith sky news kent